dr. by opening the valve on the economy
this is lawmakers work to resolve a
standoff over to that coronavirus relief
bill after was blocked by Democrats
there's a key vote in the Senate set for
about an hour from now coronavirus cases
surpassing 35,000 here in America now
making it the third hardest hit country
after China and Italy New York now the
epicenter of this pandemic with the
president deploying National Guard
troops to New York California and
Washington State as the White House
keeps on pushing Congress to finally
pass that stimulus package and John
Roberts is live at the White House with
the very latest from there hey John good
morning Santa good morning to you first
of all a couple of interesting things
out of the governor cuomo press
conference the fact that he is going to
begin giving certain patients the
combination of hydroxychloroquine and is
it through mysen that's definitely a
topic for tonight's coronavirus briefing
as well as the fact that he's calling on
the President to put the defense
production act into action and not rely
on what he called ad-hoc volunteerism
now the president announcing yesterday
that he is going to be deploying the
National Guard to California New York
State and Washington state and paying
100 percent of the cost of that in a
memorandum the president saying that the
National Guard will be involved in
preventing mitigating and responding to
the threat to public health and safety
posed by the virus that these states
undertake using their National Guard
forces the president spoke about it
yesterday's coronavirus briefing listen
here and through FEMA the federal
government will be funding 100% of the
cost of deploying National Guard units
to carry out approved missions to stop
the virus well those governors remain in
command so the governors locally are
going to be in command and will be
following them and we hope they can do
the job and I think they will as it was
the governors by the way who asked for
this while it's not expected that the
Guard will participate in law
enforcement activities the title that
they are being deployed under title 32
does allow them to participate in law
enforcement the Posse Comitatus Act as
it's known which prevents the military
from engaging in law enforcement does
not apply under title 32 it's not likely
at the moment though that the guard will
be enforcing any kind of stay at home
order or quarantine their robos
to support state authorities
logistically in much the same way that
they mobilized in the wake of hurricanes
or other natural disasters that we did
see as we did see in Baltimore they
could be called in to assist police in
the event of some public disturbance the
president also issuing disaster
declarations for New York California in
Washington that activates a response
from FEMA which is expected to set up
temporary facilities to house patients
in the next few days the nation also one
week into the president's 15-day
guidelines to slow the spread of the
corona virus but the president
indicating as Governor Cuomo did that
can't last forever and he said at the
end of the 15-day period he would make a
decision Sandra on how to proceed all
right John Roberts who thank you for
that Sandra